[Música]
en Primera Plana
Carlos Serrano
[Música]
Bienvenidos en Primera Plana un programa
de radio Francia internacional y de
France 24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
los fenómenos climáticos extremos que
han marcado los últimos meses en el
mundo para preguntarnos cómo estamos
adaptando nuestras vidas a esta nueva
realidad planetaria para ello no nos
acompañan en este estudio Andrea
Hernández Meza doctor en planificación
urbana y geoeconomía bienvenido
mi compañera Florencia Ángeles
corresponsal de la W radio de Colombia
en París bienvenida
Sebastián Morales arquitecto asociado en
el gabinete cuadra arquitectos
bienvenidos Sebastián Gracias por
invitación la adaptación de nuestras
vidas a la nueva normalidad a este
planeta inhóspito hoy nuestro asunto en
Primera Plana
el clima extremo es la nueva normalidad
los fenómenos climáticos extremos Se
multiplican por el planeta es una
constatación el último ha sido estos
días el huracán y Ana su paso por
Estados Unidos pero el verano borea que
Acabamos de terminar ha estado marcado
por Macro incendios y sequía aquí en
Europa y no solo aquí países como
Pakistán han estado golpeados por
fuertes inundaciones que han provocado
más de un millón de muertos en todo el
país y así un cotín interminable de
fenómenos extremos cada vez nos
sorprenden menos estos fenómenos nos
estamos acostumbrando a vivir con ellos
cómo se están preparando nuestras
ciudades hoy vamos a intentar responder
a estas cuestiones Pero antes algunas
portadas de prensa diario Liberación el
verano mortífero del rotativo enumera
algunos ejemplos inundaciones en
Pakistán sequía en China incendios en
Estados Unidos y Europa La era de las
catástrofes ya está aquí dice el diario
la cuac pone el punto positivo en este
escenario catastrofista señalando que
ante la urgencia cada vez más ciudadanos
despiertan sus conciencias este otro
artículo de The Guardian señala como
crece el número de núcleos urbanos en
Estados Unidos que se hacen inhóspitos
para vivir debido a las altas
temperaturas y esta última portada del
diario alemán tat juega con la ironía de
recuperar una tradición como la siesta
después de comer En referencia Clara a
las altas temperaturas que ha registrado
el país Alemania más propias de
latitudes como las de España Bueno no sé
si podríamos decir que nos hemos
acostumbrado a vivir en lo extremo
Android bueno Pues yo diría que sí
Lamentablemente las poblaciones de
diferentes partes del mundo ahora que la
comunicación es tan rápida tan directa
se dan cuenta que pasa siempre algo en
alguna parte del planeta
estamos escuchando siempre incendios en
un extremo de inundaciones en el otro
sequías nieve que se derrite Entonces si
realmente la gente se está se está
acostumbrando pero tampoco va de la mano
con adaptarse pues lo que yo pienso y
segundo tampoco va de la mano con hacer
alguna acción
más en concreta luego vamos a ver de En
qué consisten acciones lo estamos viendo
estos días con el huracán Ian en Estados
Unidos no se Florencia además trabajando
en la prensa cada vez nos sorprende
menos este tipo de fenómenos leídos en
prensa porque ya es no sé si es la nueva
normalidad consumir este tipo de
fenómenos en prensa cada día y nuevos
claro también normalizado de cierta
manera en los medios y quizás no hace
falta a todos los trabajamos en ese
sector de ir un poquito más a la
profundidad de Cuál es la razón de que
estemos enfrentando estos fenómenos y
también qué es lo que se puede hacer y
el impacto no solamente un impacto en la
vida cotidiana de que tendremos más
calor sino también económico y a futuro
qué es lo que conlleva aquellas
temperaturas extremas o fenómenos
extremos como decía andrey con las
inundaciones y bueno si hay hay que
hacer más historias y no solamente
números y profundizar en el impacto a
largo plazo
Sebastián nos estamos acostumbrando sí
creo que sí es importante saber que los
todas estas noticias que vienen con la
con la con la información tan rápida que
tenemos hacen que
de alguna manera perdamos conciencia
creo que el llamado ahora último de a la
seguridad energética por ejemplo hace
hace que podamos de alguna manera tener
en cuenta que las cosas tal como van no
están bien el cambio climático está
cambiando por ejemplo los cursos
naturales de las de las lluvias que
hacen que hayan más lluvias más menos
días de lluvia pero más días de lluvias
torrenciales y más días de sequía y las
ciudades hoy en día no están preparadas
para eso hablemos de las ciudades un
estudio reciente concluyó que los
efectos del cambio climático sobre las
150 ciudades más pobladas en el mundo
eran hasta cinco veces más intensos que
en pueblos o entornos Rurales porque en
las ciudades afecta más vamos a
explicarlo Andrés porque la sociedad es
un sistema más cerrado pero también más
Dinámico entonces pueden crear unas
cierto fenómenos burbuja en la ciudad
tenemos más impacto ambiental más que
todo por ejemplo lo que es de gases del
efecto invernadero entonces tampoco hay
tampoco se pensaron a la hora de hacer
las ciudades que fueran amigables con el
medio ambiente nunca se pensó eso hasta
ahora que vemos que tenemos extremos de
calor o inundaciones porque creían que
los ríos nunca se iban a salir de su
curso nunca nunca pensamos en un futuro
en América Latina vemos ciudades que
tienen estos problemas que se han
construido en lugares donde no se debía
de construir uno porque es más barato
uno porque se encontraban más alejados
de los centros históricos Entonces hubo
una planificación necesitaban vivienda
necesitamos construir aquí es lo más
barato hagamos lo rápido y tampoco
pensaron que la montaña se iba a llenar
en las épocas de lluvia y se iba a venir
un lavado unos derrumbes Entonces sí voy
a preguntar nuestro arquitecto Sebastián
qué es lo que pone más atención la
ciudad los materiales el tamaño de la
población la articulación entre los
barrios de habitación y otro tipo de
barrios tiene que ver con la modernidad
en realidad las ciudades inicialmente
habían sido para caminar y para para
pasear para desplazarse en caballo una
vez que llega la modernidad la
Revolución Industrial hace que
el plan de osman en París por ejemplo
las grandes los grandes Boulevares las
grandes rotondas abren la ciudad y nos
encontramos con superficies de
pavimentos y asfalto que lo que hacen es
calentar mucho la ciudad y crear islas
de calor entonces esta situación que no
estaba prevista inicialmente
hoy en día eso con la
impermeabilización del suelo causada por
el organismo extremo que hay este esta
especie de crecimiento horizontal de las
ciudades hacen que en el caso de la
lluvia por ejemplo no podamos filtrar la
naturalmente no alimentamos la Napa
freática Al final todo eso desvía las
aguas este sucias de la lluvia hacia los
acuíferos naturales los ríos los
riachuelos Los Arroyos y no es
necesariamente lo mejor para
refrescarnos luego vamos a hablar de
soluciones Pero antes Bueno en los
últimos días Estamos viendo las imágenes
hemos visto las imágenes recientes que
desde Pakistán con esas inundaciones que
sumergieron a más de un tercio del país
y han matado al menos a 1.300 personas
Florencia como nos hemos adaptado como
sociedad estos fenómenos extremos ahí
hay ya más resignación que protesta en
Bueno nos hemos resignado a aceptarlos
yo creo que sí yo creo que las protestas
se han hecho por parte de asociaciones
No desde hace algunos años pero no creo
que haya un impacto en la en la vida
digamos diaria de una persona que dice a
partir de este momento que ya vi que se
están manifestando voy a hacer un cambio
yo creo que tristemente nos hemos
acostumbrado El ejemplo también está lo
que ocurrió este verano el verano pasado
y el anterior de que la gente corrió a
comprar ventiladores y aire
acondicionado sin que se dé cuenta de
que esto a la larga va a aumentar
justamente el calentamiento global y
entonces va a ser más difícil yo creo
que nos hemos acostumbrado no de la
mejor manera no para hacer una
conciencia también como al inicio de a
ver estamos haciendo a corto plazo las
medidas pero hay que pensar un poco más
lo que estoy haciendo hoy que va a pasar
no que qué repercusión va a tener más
adelante y eso nos hace falta como como
ser humano no de de intentar y como
Ciudadano de decir esas acciones son
para mí No únicamente dependen del
gobierno no tengo que llegar una guerra
como la de Ucrania para que hablemos de
cosas que en teoría pueden parecer tan
normales como la sobriedad energética es
que eran conceptos que antes no los
manejábamos como como ahora los
manejamos cada día es esta esta idea de
cómo generar energía
nos nos ha provocado
maneras de repensar como generarla de
manera más verdes Pero si hablamos
digamos de hacer represas
hidroeléctricas estamos teniendo sequías
cómo Entonces cómo vamos a generar
eólicas las eólicas contaminan de cierta
manera Sonora pero o sea es es es
energía limpia Entonces se piensa además
estamos hablando cuando esta situación
de la guerra que es un sistema tan
grande interconectado que de pronto una
parte del sistema se corta y no tenemos
soluciones rápidas para tratar de llenar
ese hueco y ahora nos vemos con
problemas que vamos a tener por lo menos
aquí en Europa o en Francia de lo que es
la energía para el invierno
ante todo este fenómeno que estamos
describiendo veamos cómo nos organizamos
qué pueden hacer los grandes núcleos
urbanos la planificación urbana para
intentar mitigar estos efectos en
grandes líneas
primero pensar bien y delinear políticas
públicas se necesitan políticas públicas
claras sencillas y que se piensen a
mediano y a largo plazo porque esto ya
hay un momento en que no tiene vuelta de
hoja verdad Sebastián en el caso de
París para la crisis energética hay el
gobierno ha puesto en práctica muchos
muchas ayudas y subvenciones
departamentales regionales europeas
nacionales también
pero tiene un lado paradójico que es que
el gobierno incita a rehabilitar
energéticamente las viviendas los
inmuebles en el país pero por otro lado
vemos que el aislamiento que usamos es
por ejemplo poliestireno que es
dependiente del petróleo Entonces si no
integramos la visión del desarrollo
sostenible en absolutamente toda la
cadena de producción de vivienda no
vamos a poder llegar a un buen Puerto
Porque si pensamos que vamos a llenar de
poliestireno todo el parque inmobiliario
de París por ejemplo es Es imposible de
pensar Pues en París como en la ciudad
monumento o como la ciudad histórica que
creo que conocemos qué ejemplos
podríamos dar de ciudades y organismos
que estén enfrentando bien este problema
vamos a poner ejemplos si se atreven en
Latinoamérica yo he visto un poco las
las políticas y los trabajos que se han
hecho en curitiba en Brasil realmente
han intentado reverdecer
partes de la ciudad han intentado que es
vamos a ver si cubrir el cemento con
nuevas políticas de de reforestar dentro
de la ciudad también en Estados Unidos
en la ciudad de Chicago y San Francisco
han tenido políticas de poner los
impermeabilizantes bueno Que reflejen
este albedo como se llama
del sol y también tratar de hacer estas
Terrazas verdes
Sebastián alguno más allá hay ejemplos
interesantes por ejemplo en Barcelona
hay este concepto de la súper manzana en
donde se agrupan cuatro o cinco manzanas
normales se suprime el desplazamiento
vehicular y se aprovecha en crear
espacios verdes para de nuevo
permeabilizar el suelo y poder
alimentarla en ambas freática súper
importante
se ha criticado Por una parte de la
población pero como suele pasar casi
siempre no con este tipo de medidas que
al principio hay una posición feroz
igual que en París por ejemplo cuando se
ocuparon por peatones los que de la cena
y y las los nuevos ejes que han sido
plantados en esta actual gestión
hoy han habido muchas protestas de los
usuarios de los vehículos de los
motorizados sin embargo nos encontramos
con una ciudad mucho más amable
polémicas por ejemplo también con el
plan de bicicletas que se hizo también
en París tengo mucho rechazo y al final
a raíz también de la crisis de del cómic
no fue un poquito más aceptado y también
bueno París ahorita está ya el próximo
16 de octubre empieza a analizar este
que se llama París París 50 Perdón y es
el escenario de programarse a Que las
temperaturas en París alcancen los 50
grados centígrados y como las personas
que viven aquí van a adaptarse a esas
temperaturas tan extremas voy a hacer
una pausa en este punto en unos
instantes seguimos hablando de cómo
vivimos nuestra nueva normalidad con
este clima inhóspito lo hacemos aquí en
Primera Plana hasta ahora
Enlace del cono Sur a Norteamérica de
los Andes a Centroamérica una cita
semanal con los temas más importantes de
los países del continente americano
presentada por los corresponsales de
France 24
enlace en France 24 y France 24.com
Seguimos aquí en Primera Plana esta
semana hablando de cómo nos adaptamos
Cómo se adaptan nuestras vidas a la
nueva normalidad de los fenómenos
extremos al clima extremo Cómo se están
adaptando nuestras ciudades lo hacemos
con el doctor en planificación urbana
andrei Hernández Meza con nuestra
compañera corresponsal de la doble u
Florencia Ángeles y con Sebastián
Morales arquitecto asociado al gabinete
cuadra arquitectos Bueno una de las
consecuencias sin duda de estos
fenómenos extremos que estamos viendo
cada día en los medios de comunicación
el último el huracán y en estos días en
Estados Unidos es por ejemplo el de la
sequías extremas que van a ser que van a
condicionar las migraciones sin duda
estamos Florencia las puertas de graves
migraciones crisis migratorias hacia
otras latitudes que vamos a tener que
gestionar es decir la figura del
refugiado climático ha llegado para
quedarse
Y eso se ha advertido por parte de los
expertos justamente del grupo no del Jet
que han estado con estos informes de los
impactos Porque hay lugares que van a
estar pues ya rebasados por el agua
entonces la gente de ahí tiene que irse
a otras ciudades la gente que ya no va a
tener agua también que tiene que moverse
para poder tener pues este elemento
sustancial y yo creo que es algo que no
se dan cuenta también los países y los
gobiernos no sobre todo en Europa
estamos muy acostumbrados a tener esta
acostumbrados una vez más No unos
acostumbra tristemente a las situaciones
graves como los los migrantes que vienen
de muchos países de África y ahora
también dentro de los mismos países
tendrás estas migraciones de las
regiones no eh que se van quedando con
temperaturas más extremas o sin recursos
a estas ciudades que las ciudades
tampoco están adaptadas para para esta
situación no Sebastián
digamos que el tema de la inmigración
pone la pregunta rápida de la creación
de vivienda en las ciudades no como debe
crear la vivienda una ciudad como París
o como Barcelona o en América Latina
debe continuar expandiéndose de manera
horizontal O es que debe identificarse
Porque el código nos ha enseñado que
quizás la hiperdensificación no es
necesariamente lo mejor ha cambiado las
dinámicas este de las familias ahora es
este súper importante tener un espacio
exterior o un jardín y eso va contra el
concepto de densidad de y de
equipamiento de Ciudad Exacto es lo que
se llama eh lo de la ciudad de los 15
minutos que ha desarrollado se ha
desarrollado desde ayuntamientos como el
de París tener todos los servicios a 15
minutos de tu puerta pero claro eso
entra en colisión con tener grandes
espacios verdes grandes espacios y unas
ciudades menos densas Cómo se conjugan
estos dos elementos la ciudad de 15
minutos es muy interesante porque lo que
propone es
un una cosa intermedia entre la ciudad
horizontal y la ciudad altamente
identificada la ciudad de 15 minutos es
una ciudad policéntrica Qué quiere decir
que tiene varios microcentros que
permiten a cualquier persona que la
ocupa
en 15 minutos ir a un equipamiento a una
biblioteca a una escuela a comprar gozar
de todo lo que necesita en 15 minutos
caminando
claro a raíz de todo lo que estamos
conversando André y yo me hago la
pregunta y no sé si lo sabréis desde
cuándo podemos hablar históricamente de
un urbanismo sostenible cuando se empezó
a utilizar ese ese concepto cuando lo
podríamos fichar realmente cuando
empiezan las cumbres internacionales
cuando empezamos a ver estos diferentes
efectos que tienen
para mí yo hablaría de los finales de
los 60 a principios de los 70 que
realmente entra la idea de cómo
planificar a futuro después con las
diferentes
conferencias hemos visto como el tema va
poniéndose más importante
el problema es cuando se habla de estos
temas de cambio climático para políticas
y cómo van bajando poco hasta que
realmente llegan al nivel de hacer algo
entonces
se viene hablando desde hace varias
décadas de hecho estas islas de calor No
no es nada nuevo los hemos visto hace 20
años pero hasta ahora realmente que nos
afecta en las ciudades es cuando estamos
diciendo Ah sí había que hacer algo
antes y cuando ya llegamos al extremo de
que lo tenemos ya encima nos las
ciudades ahora en Europa Bueno también
en el norte de Estados Unidos Fue
demasiado calor pucha hace 20 años
teníamos hablando esto y no hicimos nada
vamos a les quiero plantear otro tema
más relacionado para empatizar más y
tener ejemplos más claros que afectan en
nuestra salud las temperaturas son una
amenaza para el corazón un análisis
realizado en cerca de 2,3 millones de
europeos ha encontrado asociaciones
perjudiciales entre el clima extremo y
las muertes por enfermedades cardíacas
especialmente en los barrios pobres que
de eso también Vamos a hablar hay
conciencia en la opinión pública de esta
relación tan directa entre salud y clima
Florencia ya me dice que no No
justamente es lo que te decía o sea se
habla mucho Nos quedamos
Lamentablemente con esta idea de que ay
sí bueno el calor extremo y las
temperaturas altas Pero no hablamos del
impacto del impacto de lo que mata
exactamente lo que te provoca estar con
este calor en tu casa que son en
ciudades le decíamos de París 50 y
justamente porque desde el verano pasado
llegamos a 46 grados en algunos lugares
de París la temperatura te dice Bueno
llega a los 39 pero justamente por esta
densidad y por este asfalto y los techos
de zinc y todo hacen que aumenta el
calor de tal manera que no te das cuenta
que llega tan alto entonces mientras no
te digan sabes que eso está teniendo un
impacto ahorita en tu salud creo que
tampoco tomas esa conciencia y eso es lo
que nos hace falta como seres humanos de
decir a ver esta temperatura de hoy me
está afectando en mi organismo en mi
desarrollo hoy mañana y a largo plazo lo
cual me lleva a preguntar puede el
urbanismo entonces ser un Aliado
amortiguador para este tipo de
enfermedades Claro que sí digamos que
las nuevas dinámicas que hay en el
organismo actual nos llevan a siempre
integrar espacios verdes espacios
que puedan ser que puedan filtrar el
agua y sobre todo la creación de islas
de frescor o de frescura que es todo lo
contrario en Isla de calor es cero
pavimento mucha la naturaleza y para
complementar lo que decía Florencia Es
importante saber que por ejemplo para
una popular una población mayor adulta
mayor los que vienen los asilos la
principal causa de muerte es la canícula
también hay que ver que no todas las
ciudades Tienen las mismas posibilidades
verdad
París en el centro generar más que todo
en lo que hablamos una densidad fuerte
que son los barrios del 18 al norte es
complicado tener espacios verdes porque
se densificó demasiado Entonces qué
tenemos que hacer tenemos que ver a lo
inmediato una manera de desplazamiento
que también se puede aplicar y que se
debe aplicar en otras ciudades para que
la gente pueda desplazarse rápido
algunos lugares donde tengan estas islas
de frescor y salgan un poco esta
densidad de este pavimento este de este
calor después ciudades
como las del norte de Europa no se
pensaron para el calor no es lo mismo
una ciudad mediterránea que Brisa Marina
que las ventanas son de diferente diseño
que una ciudad que estuvo pensada para
aguantar el frío y ahora ya no tenemos
ese frío entonces hay que adaptarse en
el en el espacio de la manera más pronta
posible porque ya está acá no sé qué
importancia le otorgan en todo este
asunto que estamos tratando hoy a la
voluntad política no sé si la voluntad
política al fin al cabo es la base de un
organismo sostenible el apostar
claramente por ello no todas las
ciudades no todos los municipios tienen
esa misma voluntad no creo que esto nos
pone en la dicotomía famosa entre el
clima o la economía No de hecho hacer
cualquier cosa de manera que se inserten
en la dinámica del desarrollo sostenible
cuesta más caro pues es mucho más
costoso entonces la pregunta estamos
dispuestos a pagar ese precio
después al final de cuentas que no se ve
que tiene un impacto también en los
mercados este tipo de fenómenos O sea a
corto plazo y tristemente siempre las
medidas ecológicas o medioambientales
son las las más golpeadas no lo vemos
ahora también con lo de la guerra en
Ucrania el plan que tenía el gobierno de
cerrar las centrales nucleares no en
Francia al final que dicen Bueno ya no
porque no podemos depender delga ruso
Entonces vamos a ir más a la energía
nuclear Pero bueno El caso es que
siempre son las medidas que dicen Bueno
después lo vemos no Ahorita hay que
responder de urgencia y el plan que yo
ya tenía pues se pasa segundo plano el
plan medioambiental Tendremos que poner
en valor los beneficios a largo plazo
que no hemos trabajado lo
suficientemente en ellos y crear este
diálogo de a ver en todos los medios de
comunicación que se así como está
ahorita la cuestión de la agenda de
equidad de género también está la
cuestión del clima ya como una constante
y no como un hecho más no como una
noticia de último momento por una
catástrofe es porque el impacto en la
vida de todos no en todas las partes del
mundo
es latente la nueva normalidad del clima
extremo va a condicionar todo en las
futuras sociedades el urbanismo la forma
de organizarse la forma de organizar el
sistema de salud las migración es la
forma de relacionarnos también entre los
humanos Esto no significa que el mundo
esté indefenso según los expertos
reducir las emisiones de gases de efecto
invernadero aún puede reducir el riesgo
de desastres climáticos a medio plazo en
el corto plazo los seres humanos pueden
mitigar los desastres a través de la
adaptación utilizando pues por ejemplo
una mejor gestión forestal para reducir
el riesgo de incendios forestales o por
ejemplo construyendo infraestructuras
que sean más resistente a las fuerzas
lluvias inundaciones el problema es de
nuevo en no tener los recursos los
pobres son los que más van a sufrir en
esta adaptabilidad porque claro se
necesita inversión se necesitan los
recursos Al fin y al cabo también está
la cuestión de nuevo de la justicia
social
sí Lamentablemente son las zonas donde
más necesitadas que son las que están
impactadas directamente porque son las
que no se planearon se hicieron de
manera rápida para rellenar necesidades
y y son donde las políticas públicas a
veces no ven directamente porque hay una
necesidad una inversión que se tiene que
proteger antes que otras zonas y estas
zonas van a ser las que después con
estos movimientos de población ya sea
porque no hay donde vivir ya sea porque
no hay que comer ya sea porque hay una
desertificación van a meter presiones a
las zonas urbanas que siempre han sido
las las zonas que más riqueza han
generado de Entonces ahí es donde la
gente va a buscar el trabajo a buscar
Entonces como como como como como
dijeron se necesita sí
horizontal y vertical Cómo manejamos
esto con estas presiones que llegan de
las zonas más necesitadas
sí creo que la clave
lo que pasa por entender que hoy en día
las reglas hacen que construir una un
edificio de viviendas y equipamiento
hace que sea muy muy sostenible pero el
problema no está ahí el problema está en
lo existente en lo que ya está
construido normalmente nos encontramos
en la periferia edificios de muy poca
calidad con fachadas muy muy ligeras muy
febles que hacen que que el impacto del
calor y el frío se instantáneo Entonces
es ahí donde se tiene que intervenir Y
esa Y es ahí donde no lo estamos
haciendo Lamentablemente adaptarse a
ello claro ahí entra el elemento de la
justicia social los barrios más pobres
lógicamente lo van a sufrir
una manera Más directa y tampoco pueden
tener esta muchas veces esta elección no
tienen una la primera cubrir las
necesidades básicas no Entonces eso
también es uno de los principales retos
y también algo que nos ha tomado en
cuenta es pues también el impacto que
hay por ejemplo de todas esas sequía en
la falta de alimento que también eso es
muy grave y el encarecimiento ahorita
que estamos hablando también de
inflación y todo no se dice mucho sobre
las cosechas no el hecho de que ahorita
ya se han perdido muchísimas porque o
tenemos mucha sequía y luego llega la
lluvia de manera torrencial de todas
maneras se pierde las cosechas y esto
Entonces el año que viene te da a menos
eh menos alimentos y entonces también
otra vez los más pobres son los que se
enfrentan a este riesgo de no poder
cubrir esa necesidad básica al final ese
famoso equilibrio entre Ecología y
Justicia social está detrás de muchos de
los debates que tratamos aquí en Primera
Plana pero en muchísimos en muchísimos
debates de la sociedad actual el famoso
equilibrio entre Ecología y Justicia
social y lo difícil que es ponerlo en
equilibrio esos dos conceptos verdad
pues ha sido un placer Muchísimas
gracias Andrea y Florencia Sebastián por
haber compartido con nosotros este
tiempo y a todos ustedes les esperamos
aquí en Primera Plana la próxima semana
gracias
[Música]